elle est pour en parler nous sommes avec
rudy caisse des cofondateurs de oui la
nouvelle afrique bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors quel bilan est ce
qu'on peut faire justement de cet accord
signé à hell yeah man c'est très mitigé
très mitigé parce que michel d'auto dia
et françois bozizé sont retournés au
bercail
françois bozizé d'ailleurs l'ancien
président a peiné essayer de l'avoir
rendez vous avec le post archange
touadéra finalement sous la pression de
l'union africaine et de certains
observateurs à tendance est appelée qui
est là michel chassang président
l'ancien président rebelle à présent
rebelles et françois bozizé également et
c'était très compliqué pour françois
bozizé il est rentré dans le palais
présidentiel en disant comme si c'était
un peu son bureau et puis finalement
touadéra l'a reçu avec deux chaises de
séance une table loin du bureau en
disant ben voila je te reçoivent ce
qu'on m'a dit ' recevoir mais je dois
faire plus d'efforts pour toi c'est
compliqué c'est à dire que tout les
éléments de le concours national ne sont
pas encore réunies
alors oui sur papier on a signé un
accord il faut donner l'expression la
place de l'expression politique pour
tous les représentants de la cité civile
et politique centrafricaine ce qui est
compliqué puis ajoutez à ça vous avez
aussi un problème par exemple sur les
financements de grands projets le
développement pour le financer alors on
fait des grandes conférences
internationales à bruxelles un peu
partout pour rassembler des fonds du
milliard d'euros mais est ce qu'il ya un
but ludique était construit et qui
l'entreprise ces patients non plus pour
que les mecs arrête de prendre là où il
faut qu'ils aient un emploi pour qu'il
ya un emploi il faut une stabilité
politique
alors on va essayer commencer par
l'emploi tant qu on y est allé on a
ramené de l'argent il ya les entreprises
sont là les gars sont là
est ce que les entreprises fonctionnent
visiblement pas trop avoir les
entreprises d'extraction en voyant
comment on fait les politiques et ce
qu'ils peuvent
et des ah bah non parce qu'ils sont
occupés par leurs strapontins politique
alors l'entreprise qui peut l'aider
personnes dans l'entreprise cinéma vient
pas mais les deux milliards alors ben on
verra pour plus tard et tout est comme
ça en fait donc c'est pour ça que non le
bilan est très mitigé sur papier c'est
super et dans la pratique c'est
et la réforme de l'armée ou est-ce qu'on
en est à ce niveau parce que ça aussi ça
un point important en matière de
réconciliation nationale et d'avancer
aussi oui alors là par contre il ya eu
de beaux efforts qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on a intégré les meilleurs lieutenants
de tous les candidats et on leur a dit
bon allez on prend ces c'est comme sur
une liste aux municipales
bon bah on va faire une alliance on
prend les quatre les quatre premiers de
chaque personne qui est derrière le
major et puis on les fait rentrer mais
les dix autres derrière qui attendent
aussi leur place on leur dit le tour
prochain
ça arrive c'est donc le problème c'est
que ces gens là aussi disait et moi la
part du gâteau escalettes et donc au
final on essaye de composer en faisant
rentrer les éléments les imbriquer des
uns avec les autres mais donc c'est
comme à bout de sparadrap sur une plaie
encore encore béantes et ben oui ça
s'arrête a grondé de couler le sang mais
il suffit que ya une mini cicatrices et
puis et puis ça peut repartir
l'autre paramètre important si c'est
l'insécurité dans les pays qu'ils
constat vous faites à ces niveaux est ce
qu'on en est là encore une fois alors
centrafrique c'est très simple on
arrêtera de prendre les armes
s'il ya du travail qui rémunèrent mieux
que les armes alors on a un programme
géant sur l'agriculture en disant
laisser tomber la kalachnikov ou autre
chose et puis commence à planter un
oignon ce que l'oignon braves ont
toujours pas plus que la kalachnikov
donc c'est là c'est là le problème le
jour où on ira les deux milliards de
bruxelles
arrivé avec une reconstruction
d'entreprise de start up et que la
diaspora
implantées en france et en belgique
s'applique un peu plus sur le
développement du pays
alors les gars accepteront de travailler
alors les groupes armés qu'ils sont
encore actifs
qui sont ces groupes armés aujourd'hui
des groupes armés ils sont issus de
faction pour certaines d'entre elles
armé par les canadiens avec notamment le
concours aussi d'armes qui circulent à
l'est de la rd congo qui arrivent
jusqu'au nord de la centrafrique
donc voilà qui sont ces groupes armés se
sont aussi des courses à faire des
anciens mercenaires qui ont fui lé
l'armée régaliennes pour constituer
leurs propres groupes de combat pourquoi
parce que c'est de cette manière qu'ils
veulent prendre le pouvoir puisque vous
parlez des tchadiens on évoque souvent
une mainmise du tchad sont une partie de
7,7 saint-affrique justement cette
république centrafricaine quelle est la
réalité avait idriss déby le président
du tchad a fait un truc bien il s'est
fait une super bonne armée sous
l'inspiration de son ami sidaner
l'ancien président omar el béchir
donc s'il veut faire la police dans
toute la région savais que j'allais au
moins une bonne armée comme ça par la
force ont fait calmer les esprits les
plus les plus récalcitrants et les plus
téméraires donc y conseille la
centrafrique en disant écoute si tu peux
de développement économique et social et
au moins une bonne attaque se
maintiendra un peu la paix pour tout le
monde et donc ils aideraient débit jouit
d'une très bonne popularité auprès des
présidents notamment sur les questions
sécuritaires
je vais prendre un exemple le soudan est
en train de se rapprocher d'israël
politiquement pour des raisons
militaires qui a été à l'origine de ça
monsieur débit parce que monsieur débit
achètent des armes à tout le monde ce
débit à la meilleure armée de toute la
sous région et donc de ce fait ils
donnent les gentils conseils pour cette
gentil voisin qu'il aime qu'il
affectionne tant particulièrement parce
qu'il ne veut surtout pas que dans son
pays le tchad y ait le moins de
problèmes insurrectionnelle il sera par
contre il peut exporter son conseil son
expertise et envoyer ses hommes
notamment comme une feuille nigeria il
ça rapporte un peu de sous pour le tchad
ça il n'y voit aucun l'élection
présidentielle qui va avoir les dents
dix mois en centrafrique
les perspectives
des candidats on imagine qu'ils seront
en lift avec le président actuel aussi
qui risquent de se représenter peut-être
alors
sur la ligne de départ tout est beau
honorable je te dia on aura du monsieur
moïse et on n'aura d'yeux sétois des
rares prend les mêmes et on recommence
il va envoyer son pion si c'est pas lui
il va envoyer un de ces gars pour leur
présenter de manière officieuse mais où
est-ce que ça va se passer
34 coups de téléphone par
l'intermédiaire de t'avoir de monsieur
idriss deby en dix ans on a voulu
soutenir le gap à lui parce que bon non
lui on ne sait pas vraiment comment il
pense lui ont lu ça rassure donc là pas
de problème puis à monsieur tshisekedi
aussi de la rdc qui va atteindre que y
ait un peu des répercussions de
mouvements de la centrafrique vers la
rdc et qui est monsieur kagame du rwanda
qui est à l'est de la rdc
clairement les gars va falloir qu'on
s'entende à quand on fait une élection
entre nous pour montrer à la communauté
internationale
mais par contre on sait que ça va jouer
on va pas les feux très bon toi tu as
gagné dans toute la période
ap 15 % et ils vont c'est de se
départager le le gâteau comme ça et de
faire en sorte que vous évoquez
finalement c'est que l'ess qu'on
comprend c'est que la centrafrique elle
sous influence de ses voisins d'une
influence régionale voire étrangères
abba régional oui ce pays s'appelle un
but sans qu'africaine aussi
l'emplacement de l'afrique
donc il porte bien son nom et on se
retrouve dans une situation maintenant
où tout ce qui s'y passe là bas peut
avoir des répercussions de l'équipe i
jusque rwanda donc je peux vous dire que
pays voisin dont aucun intérêt à voir
une conflagration énorme par rapport à
la situation en centrafrique et à côté
de ça vous avez un pays un pays riche de
minerais donc les états unis la russie
la france bientôt israël la chine aux
intérêts ce que tout ce petit monde
s'entende et que s'il ya un peu de
rivalité
je sois un peu plus l'attend mais pacs
explose trop donc chacun va vouloir
ramener un peu le calme un peu de feu
mais ramener l'eau pour 8 couvrir le feu
et puis bon bah on va faire en sorte que
ça dure comme ça et puis toute façon ça
a toujours fait comme ça qui on comptera
sur monsieur kagamé au contrat sur
monsieur idriss deby qui même s'ils ne
peuvent pas supporter dans un salon
feutré sur le cas de la centrafrique
vont devoir se parler pour faire en
sorte qu' une stabilité dans la région
et ça désigne pas sur l'ensemble de la
région et y compris sur la rdc où l'aca
pourrait prendre
une ration énorme d'après de vue
économique sociétal et même militaire
merci beaucoup ri di gasby vous est le
cofondateur de whip la nouvelle afrique
merci pour cette analyse
merci beaucoup